[Music]
hello and we are live welcome to psytrek
all you lovely sidetrackers and welcome
to stormy my resident american
hello hello
alan copeland is with us already david
is already with us
and i'll go do that twice let me switch
hello stormy how are you mate
i'm not in ukraine so i'm doing quite
well
we're all not in ukraine so we're all
doing better than ukrainians
um
we won't talk politics because that's
not what we do here but
world war three
that's a distinct possibility [ __ ] your
favorite world war three film
oh dear i tell you that's a conversation
what's your favorite dystopian the
russians have destroyed everything
um what's your favorite dystopian movie
get in the comments
um but yeah
today we decided we're actually gonna
have a chat about
really terrible like b movies really bad
movies that we adore but first of all i
wanted to have a bit of a chat about
um
highlander movie
is officially getting a reboot
so i just wanna have a quick chat about
that henry cavill is it's official it's
confirmed henry cavill is going to be
the highlander and i just i just want
it's one of my favorite movies from back
in the day you know um oh yeah
if they don't have some queen tracks in
there though i will leave the cinema
it's i will leave the cinema and i will
punch the um attendant in the face on
the way out
it's um
i just want to let you know there are no
new queen tracks coming right you know
that right what what no they're just
throwing a few older ones what do you
whatever they actually did release a new
album a couple of years ago so like
literally like two years ago they
released a new album so i think they can
just do that
i do
ian is it ian you'll have to tell me how
are you mate how are you
um but yeah i think they could just
throw something together and
75 of the band is still alive
so they could do something but um yeah
it wouldn't be the same with it but they
just need to throw on a few little
tracks not going silly but what do you
think first of all go ask you what do
you think about henry cavill
being the highlander
any movie or any anything that henry
cavill's in with a big ass broadsword i
i can't like argue that makes you any
small you know it's just like richard
you know
we know he can swing an axe so yeah
he'll do all right in it
i just wonder that the last time they
had a guy from belgium play a scottish
fella and a scottish fellow player guy
from egypt i think he was
and and scottish people got very angry
so now they've cast an english guy to do
it i'm pretty sure they'll be fine with
that
the the scottish they they love us so
i'm pretty sure though and henry cavill
i can't imagine him doing a scottish
accent i think it's going to go badly
but um
i'm actually really looking forward to
it because i think the highlander is a
film that needs a reboot
and i know 95 of my videos are about
reboots but
that's what i actually want to see
um
but i actually did a video on this five
months ago so you heard it on my channel
eight years ago that
highlander hello like exclusive
um but
i said they should change the ramirez
character to a woman
so they should change the sean connery
character to a woman
oh i got some stick for that
oh i got i got yelled at in text people
put it in capitals oh my god
yeah they're really angry but i argued i
said i think it's a really good idea
because
sean connery's character was like a
father figure wasn't it to sean connery
right uh two and so sorry to um to the
highlander
so what did he yeah he was kind of like
the daddy
yeah so what's worse than losing a
father figure losing a mommy figure
yeah
but also
i think it would be funny seeing a
little woman beat up henry cavill you
know when they're doing like their
training sequences at the start oh yeah
yeah yeah just beating the [ __ ] out that
would be funny yeah and i think michelle
you should do
i want to see michelle you do it because
she can throw a sword around oh my god
yeah
so yeah genius people yelled at me for
that but actually
i've thought it through
so uh henry cavill and some little
asian girl we're gonna be in the
highlander movie
i think you know that would be
what does the the asian girl also have a
scottish accent
male should be asian
okay
i just i'm so confused you know because
there's the the outrage in the lord of
the rings community over something
over everything man they're very angry
about that um i've never been a huge
lord of the rings fan so i do not care
the slightest about the lord of the
rings tv series i'm sure i'll watch it
um but i watched and i watched the the
bit they've released you know um and now
it doesn't interest me in the slightest
um
but hey
we'll have to see
what happens it's thousands of years
before hello isn't it so does that mean
gandalf will be in it again are they
gonna have to young
five serene mccoy
because gandalf is an old bugger old
bugger what you know i don't know um i
haven't seen anybody announced that's
gonna be playing gandalf i know it's uh
most most of the story is about
galadriel in her backstory
i don't want to see that
that's just terrible i think we just
you know normally like like star trek at
the moment people are saying oh we've
got this star trek fatigue i got lord of
the rings fatigue during the movie i
mean like by the end of the film by like
nine hours into the film i was sort of
like a bit bored of this
but then the hobbit films came out and
they were just bad they were just boring
i go as far as some um some little
bearded fellas singing and i thought
i've had enough of this now i'm just
turning off
i wondered often did housework because
it was more interesting
i'm so sorry i know it was just just
rubbish
um
yeah
ian's with me on that he doesn't want me
to talk about um sean connery's becoming
susan sean connery but
i read a lot of rings when i was at
school as well me um
i think i read lord of the rings though
because i thought it was a really big
book i thought that's a challenge that's
it right there
yeah but no i didn't enjoy it so but no
great movies brilliant films i didn't
watch the hobbit ones but the lord of
the rings films are fantastic and the
scope of them
i just wonder if they're trying to find
the next game of thrones and they're
doing they'll literally do
anything
um i'm just gonna do yeah i mean there's
the uh along is concerning the power of
the rings it's um who knows everything's
so tight-lipped
you know about
there's so many question marks you know
when so when you do like the fellowship
of the ring you kind of know what that
story is
but you know tolkien
wrote so damn much on everything and
none of it you know
the problem with the i guess the uh
loader community is being all outraged
well which version of tolkien's story
are you outraged over i mean he'd take
one story and that he'd write 10
different versions
you know and it and well which one's
canon he never told us he didn't care he
just went oh here's this and the stuff
it actually got
published
doesn't exactly line up i mean it's just
it's really it's all kind of isn't it if
he wrote it the other day it's kind of
sorry but right yeah so what happens
when the author writes conflicting
timelines
it's still canon
it means amazon can do whatever the hell
they like it means amazon can do
whatever the hell they at least
like to do whatever within reason they
they they prefer that to be honest i
think and um and i actually think they
like the controversy anyway i'm sure
they probably sneak these little things
in to have a bit of controversy because
anything that creates clicks
anything anything gets people like us on
our channels are arguing and um and
complain or complain and it's just great
because it just creates clicks
yeah and that's what they love so i'm
having a bit of an issue with that at
the moment with stargate
and and the expanse to be honest
so um there's a lot of rumors flying
around about the expanse returning to
our screens um and and i've been talking
to people that i talked to and they were
basically telling me that amazon's had
gone off it they weren't they were they
were thinking they weren't going to push
on with it and they thought about doing
a series of movies and then they changed
their minds
um
so then warner brothers
were thinking oh hbo max
look expansive look nice on that so they
apparently they were sniffing around
without khan who produced the show
but now it looks like it was all rubbish
it all looks like it was all lies
um or room is just to get clips because
amazon apparently are considering
keeping hold of it there's going to be a
break but they are seriously considering
keeping all of it and coming back and
doing the seven eight at night but they
want to wait two or three years but i
think they want to wait two or three
years and just have as much like
as many arguments going on as possible
in the meantime
but i think the same is going on with
stargate you know and i think after you
know at some point in time some point in
time you know click bait is just not
going to work anymore in terms of
advertising like pop-up ads after a
certain point of time they lost
effectiveness
so you know i think the same thing is
going to be for uh clickbait so then i'm
not sure where they go from there you
know in unless you know see gandalf in
the new you know
lord of the rings
with the new stargate
you know or picard you know in the
hobbit four i mean it's just it's got to
be some sort of crazy mashup just to
piss this ever piss all of us off well
it got confirmed in the week that
picard's going to be in the new um
marvel movies he's going to be in um
yeah yeah
doctor strange too
yes it's definitely definitely patrick
stewart's voice so
jean-luc picard mashup star trek it's
marvel definitely 100
um or professor x definitely one of the
two there
um well probably a professor x do you
think
oh well
it's
it'd be it's i i think that's more like
i think that's more obvious and i think
marvel liked to take you the other way
so and it is supposed to be
silly it's definitely professor x but um
i i i i can't wait for it i think that
movie that new doctor strange film must
be about nine hours long because i mean
looking at the advert well it is a
multiverse
yeah a lot happens
so the difference is for every you know
so
they'll be sending them a different damn
version
the trailer is not ours i hated it i
loved it i think we started talking each
other
[Music]
yeah you had to go all over town to see
the whole thing
we don't do things like that anymore
thanks i love that
friday it's i'm trying to remember the
last time i actually went to the theater
i think recovered
now we i see there was one
uh
it may be in a spiderman
homeward
no way home
no way huh another one before my home
was only a few months ago
so
this was uh
the one before when he's uh on the field
trip
yes the field trip right right
uh i don't think alan i don't think
they've and then so he's just asking
about doctor who the 14th doctor there's
a lot of rumors going around
um
that they want to do something really
big for the 14th doctor there's even
talk about it being david tennant again
um i've seen tennant's name come up i've
seen tom baker's name come up and
i don't think tom baker can run around
like tennant used to i'm sure tom baker
can walk but he's i don't he did it i'm
not being facetious there he's a big
fella and um and he's he's not doing
very well for a few years i don't think
but they could do it he would do it if
you give off a chance he loves that
something he's got one of those voices
as well as it's like
yeah that's
um
but yeah there's been a few things that
they want to do something big but
we'll see i think it's the same jody
whittaker's not carrying on because i
thought she was great
to be honest
i mean her acting was fun you know i i
thought the way she brought uh the
entrance she brought a lot of interest
to the character it's just man
the writing it's just badly right yeah
the the only episode i liked of the jody
foster series was the one um
where they thought she was dr d
it's immensely i stopped watching i'm
not sure i even saw that episode
i've stopped watching after my smith
to be honest no we're watching his
pirates
matt smith i thought was good i thought
he's great he's the one thing i'm
looking forward to in the game of
thrones prequel actually because oh
what's that uh
something something dragon what's the
houston
house of the dragon yeah how's the
dragon yeah
um i think he looks i i think he'll be
great in that it's a shame that last
terminator terminator genesis kind of
failed because he was in that but he was
supposed to be in the sequel more
um so the
old things that he's just like set up in
that and but then he never really seemed
a great deal um but then obviously it
bombed horribly
and um and so they never made it but
that would have been that would have
been good because he's he's one of those
actors and he's just a really likable
actor so he moves or something
really likeable
um but anyway let's get into the subject
where we actually came to talk okay
idris albert is doing everything
he will be doctor who he will be james
bond and he will be everything else as
well
yeah yeah it'll it'll make thing life
easier if everything is interesting that
would make life much easier
right so
the the point of this evening's brief
discussion
um is that we're going to talk about
films like b movies that we we loved
i used to love a great b movie when i
was a kid yeah um
them is a film that i love
back from the 50s you know whenever you
hear a car drive fastening off
because the um timing belt slipped right
that's the noise that the ants made in
them i know it always makes me think i'm
always looking at my shoulder making
sure our massive ant isn't going to
appear from the sides
no no ants
um but that's that's one of those great
moves and it's one of those films it's
funny but it doesn't mean to be
um and you you watch it you sort of like
that's that's great there's a man like
him crashing a big rubber and going
[Laughter]
and um and i'm cracking myself laughing
but it's not intentional it doesn't it
doesn't mean to be funny at all um
so we thought we'd have a chat about all
those films that we
were a little bit embarrassed to love
um so yeah guys get in the comments any
film so you can think of that you
you know
guilty pleasures
the viewers have to say like so then we
could comment on their uh best worst
headaches that would be very cool so
anybody that wants to please do that but
i'm going to crack on because i say i've
already hooked up the dvd
for when we're done with this i'm going
to go get some food and everything and
i'm going to watch dog soldiers
from 2002
which is a film i normally don't do like
horror movies but it's not really a
horror movie i don't know if you've seen
it as a british film they didn't do
particularly well
but it's a um
it's a werewolf movie
um oh something just floated up past me
though that's like so i think i might
have a ghost oh my god
it's a spirit
it's it all
um
so i was watching
hey nana how you doing
um so i was so yeah it's one of those
films that i watched when i was a when i
back in the day sort of things like
that's 18 years or 20 years ago now
um
and it's just
bad but it is funny in places but it's
intentionally funny like at one point it
is a bunch of soldiers and they're in
the scottish highlands and they
basically get hunted down by a bunch of
werewolves
um
and at one point the soldier he gets his
belly cut and his guts are pouring out
he's like oh the bloody hell are they
doing that they shouldn't be there and
they're trying to push all of these guts
back in and he's and it's just it's just
funny and then he just gets better
because he's very bit so he's becoming
aware of she just gets better and
everyone's like you know that's assange
you're getting a bit better but um
the werewolf are not good they've got
these big rubber heads at one point a
werewolf comes through and it hits
something on the door frame and you
literally see the noise go boiling
the rubber nose do that
but it's a great movie
and
rocco has just said there the underworld
movies as well to be fair they're the
other great werewolf
i like those i thought they were
brilliant to be honest i thought they
were beautifully made
um
i i think the um i think those ones was
one of the first ones you know if they
do she does the superhero step and she
steps off the um
the clock tower and then she just goes
and walks okay beckenstein just goes
walking walking walk yes so hot but um
but yeah so dog soldiers is a film after
i started only think about this i'm
thinking that's a film i'm watching
tonight
um
some more mystery theater 3000. that was
the thing with it that was bigger in
america than over here i believe but
isn't that the thing that was kind of
presented by the little robot thing
was that that
uh well yeah there is um oh what were
the name of the robots um
they started with two one was like a
bubble gum machine
and there was three gypsy
i want to say something like like a
calendar for a head or something
yeah one yeah um
gypsy
tom servo was tom servo gypsy and what
was the other one
that's like we didn't really have it
it was over here and i've seen it but it
wasn't like a big thing but um i assume
it was a bit bigger in america than was
it was it it was what was it when it was
late night
oh god yeah uh
sci-fi channel thing yeah
and um
marvin the paranoid android no i don't
think that was it
um
but yeah i see i i vaguely remember that
but i didn't really watch it but how
about yourself what other
things have you
seen over the years that you've sort of
okay well the my as i was mentioning
earlier before we uh started streaming
rocky horror picture show has to be the
king modi movie that everybody loves but
can't show grandma
oh no god no i can't watch i mean you
know it's we we've all gone to see it
we've all done the underwear run you
know we've thrown the toast we've thrown
the rice
i couldn't find any stockings to fit me
mix i i used to play rugby so i got
rugby placed ice so i couldn't get
stockings to fit me
sounds like a bit of a threat but um
yeah i i love those movies and um a
little shopper horror as well
um i love those as well um
i i don't think those are i think those
are films that are very much what
they're supposed to be though and i
think they're so why are they b movies
i'm not sure
but um they're gloriously crazy
right 100
i would say anything with bruce and
bruce campbell
yes definitely qualifies as yeah
army of darkness is one of the most
awesome ridiculous stupid movies
i've ever seen and at times it's
hilarious and i think sometimes it means
to be and sometimes i'm not sure what
it's meaning to be
but it's um
it's just it's just bruce campbell
he's it is at his glorious best there
was a movie you mentioned to me because
i've sat and watched clips of it since
bubba hotel
that was a really popular movie i'd
never heard of it until you mention it
i mean well it was
it's got a cult following yes i mean it
was uh
no one really saw it until i got on
cable you know no one went to the
theater but it was uh
man what was this like the early night
when was this let me go look it up
early night 2002 apparently it was bubba
hotep aussie davis
yep i know it's bruce campbell as um
elvis isn't it doesn't he
that's right yeah and the other guy
thinks he's jfk
right yeah yeah and he had a and he had
the presidential red phone
yeah oh and he had um he had a
suspicious scar in the back of his head
but i don't think i know about that he
was a black guy
right auntie davis man he was the
hollywood legend yeah they saved his
life and and painted in black so they
could hide him
but um i love that they did um
oh in a space 1987 with dennis great
that was great and mighty short
yeah great movie
um i love that film um
let's go back to bobby bobby head bobby
tip joe blah blah blah
bubba hotep they actually released a
bunch of comics and one of the comics i
uh a novella sorry i desperately want to
read because it was a hookup between
elvis who was played by bruce campbell
and ash from the um evil dead series
his name on like their adventures i'm
like oh my god i want to see that so
much
i really want to make that they um they
did bruce campbell did a tv series a
couple of years ago over and out of the
army of darkness and it had come back
and that was great to be honest
and lee may just played his dad and he
was fantastic
there was this one it was kind of like a
um
spy action tv show that uh he showed up
in
berlin
um
oh
he was a cia agent that had gone yeah i
think well the title here in the united
states was burn notice i didn't notice
it was the same here yeah yeah it is
um i actually watched that i used to
read light burn notice
um the guy that played it though we had
weird little mouth
but oh then i've looked at things his
mouth is big enough
don't know why that's just the way my
brain works um yeah allen was a little
bit behind us but we we got there got
there just before you uh yeah
we win
um but no that was a brilliant that was
a good series that was a kind of wacky
tv series as well i want to see bruce
campbell's new movie have you seen that
with the um the black friday
film
and i heard
i do want to see it and it's it's that
is it that seems like a typical bruce
campbell movie but they're
it's a supermarket and they're about to
have their black friday sale so they're
all preparing for everyone to go nuts
and it's basically like an alien
invasion so aliens are zombies i forget
now but um
so it's like ridiculous heads explosions
and things and i desp i really really
want to see that because i just want to
see bruce campbell give me some sugar
but you know i'm just just being bruce
he's fantastic in everything
i've got a long list of here though of
other films that um
we're a sci-fi channel so we should
discuss a terrible sci-fi movie that i
love
space truckers
with dennis hopper yes oh god yes
that is a ridiculous film
how they ever got charles dance a man
that has been nominated for academy
awards
um to do
money
yeah they must have just come up with
like a wheelbarrow full of money and
just gone charles
please yeah there is a scene where
you're going to try to start your penis
like it's a rip cord
like but
it's funny and you'll love it
um
i i don't know how they're going to do
it but it's that's one of those films
you know the um
the robot in that the the thing with it
and
right that was in that was them created
by a um japanese um
comic book writer
and i actually genuinely think it's one
of the like the best android-y bad guys
um ever ever created i thought it was
fantastically done there was a genuinely
scary bad guy in that film
in a film that had um
square pigs because they were easy to
package
and that they forgot about gravity a lot
during making it there's there's a lot
of instances where they forget this that
they're supposed to be like uh metal
plates on the shoes right and they just
forget
um
it was made with like no money really
quickly but it's just
glorious in its stupidity
um
that's one of my favorite stupid sci-fi
movies
now i've got a couple on my list that
didn't do well
didn't do without the box office but i
love them
and two of them have sean connery in
them
give me this list
he's done some
so the first one was a 1981 movie with
sean connery called outland
you ever heard it i remember oh god
of this space station i think beyond
jupiter or saturn
and there was like this killer coming on
the station he just kind of had to bop
around and wait for him and then kill it
but yeah it was called outland let's see
if i can find out who else was playing
in it um
peter boyle
yeah
yeah
john ratzenberger believe it or not
and
who was the
uh
i can't remember who the bad guy is
yeah sean carner is marshall william t
o'neal of course he played the marshall
didn't he yeah that was back when he he
was still tashed
yeah that wasn't a bad movie i liked it
um
it was one of those it almost looked
like a thunderbirds movie it almost
looked like jerry anderson had done all
the special effects for it sort of thing
yeah you know um
yeah i mean it was
81 so it was you know right after star
wars but before
i wonder who did the special i don't
guess it was trumbull i don't think so
everybody was trying to do special
effects movies that weren't they went
yeah by star trek because then the star
wars was such a massive ridiculous hit
but
i mean george lucas so didn't expect
star wars would be a hit he actually
didn't go to the premiere
yeah if we go back to one of our quiz
from long ago
um he didn't think it would be
any good so he went to um
[Music]
he went to hawaii with steven spielberg
instead
and they
i'm just going to drink
outline just found a pinewood all the
great
i think we have this decision
yeah we did i mean pine pinewood's
probably one of the best studios in
europe
or if not the world
it is definitely for sci-fi movies is a
great one alan and this is actually
relevant to at the moment we'll come
back to you or this
uh sean connery movie
masters of the universe the he-man movie
that they did with dolph lundgren with
the great
golf london
that film do you know how many years of
therapy i had to go through just to get
that out of my head alan
what are you doing
evil in it was kind of hot in that film
and um skeletor was actually pretty
creepy but oh god that film is dead it
was really bad
they're remaking it though we're getting
a new he-man movie this year we've just
had the kevin smith cartoon which love
or hate
i'm i'm i'm
talk kevin smith for a second all right
i look like kevin smith fan i love kevin
smith i think dogma is one of the
greatest films ever made
that has been individual fantastic movie
but that man should not be allowed to do
anything anymore he lost his way a
little while ago as soon as he found
weed i think he he
is he went a different way
didn't he put weed in his baby bottle or
something i think he's always been on
weed no apparently he wasn't he wasn't a
big fan um well what if it was a heart
attack
well news about oh god he's been on it a
while don't get me wrong um but muse
basically got in on it and i remember
you see me he did an interview where um
because everyone assumed he was a
massive pothead
right he just said and i just wasn't i
wasn't i was a bit the geek i was at
school i just didn't
um so they um
this he did it but he did a magazine
thing for this um pop magazine whatever
it was i forget what it's called um hash
times or something and they brought a
shitload of marijuana around to like
every photo with it and he sort of said
he said he talked him into it he said i
liked it and then he became a massive
pothead and then he obviously had a
massive heart attack um
but yeah it was um you know he wasn't a
big part but but yeah so they did dogma
and they did um a couple of jane silent
bob was okay but then they did strike
back and uh
um
the he-man cartoons though
that had good bits in it
but generally speaking was
i won't swear
but it was [ __ ] awful
um
and and i really like him
really really liking it
it's
it was you know uh it came out
right and uh the um
social media world was quick to just get
all up in its grill
and then it was gone and like and then
no one talked about it and so i kind of
forgot about it until you just mentioned
it
i think oh um
steve and daniel said they're coming up
with so many great moves in the comments
now that's a full-blown comedy so it's
not really a b movie not really what
we're talking about here but
ridiculous speed is just and then
ludicrous they've gone the plan
it's just a fantastic movie in
i'm i'm a mog what's a mark i'm a half
man half dog i'm my own best friend
is
just
just amazing i love i love john candy
i'm just putting up
barbarella
i never really got barbaria
i don't i don't i think i've watched it
two or three times and i can't tell you
what the plot is
i am i just kept looking at jane fonda
hot chicks floating around i mean yeah
i genuinely can't tell you what story
was
she had a laser she was on a ship
somebody came i i don't really know what
the what the what the plot of that film
was i i can't i can't tell you it was
just like it was just like they had jane
fonda for the day so they went
let's do a sci-fi film
and this they just threw something
together i didn't i never got it well
let's go to
um
imdb and this is their description of it
barbarella an astronaut from the 41st
century sets out to find and stop an
evil scientist durand durand whose
positronic ray threatens to bring evil
back into the galaxy galaxy galaxy
i don't remember any of that was
somebody from duran geran in the film
because that's
an odd bad guy name i don't i don't
remember the being a bad guy
oh yeah durand d d-r-a-n-d
duran
okay
gold gold
i remember being a big bed or something
and i and i just remember
that
so um
this filth is over
it's john smith
i think it was probably a bit of just
filth
um it was almost soft core porn from
what i remember but i was a teenager
when i watched it so i might have been
a bit thin um oh the band apparently
named themselves after the villain john
i really hope that's true because that's
awesome if it is
well so one thing about barbarella is
one at the time one of the world's
foremost mimes marcel marceau
he was uh he played professor ping
did he say anything
yeah mimes are evil we should probably
kill all the mimes
i'm not no now that would be hate speech
so i'm not allowed to sit here in a
public forum and say that you should
kill mimes
but
you know
i'm not saying you shouldn't kill them
we'll put it that way
this is a joke this is a joke please god
don't kill your career online
yeah exactly and
do critter movies because is this is
this are you saying that the third
critter movie was uh wonderful
i i know i think they just got worse
didn't they it's in the third critters
movie though they had like no budget at
all so it's just like one hand puppet in
the corner
um
you know the critics movie reminds me of
though it is a film i actually had on my
list and tremors
which again
is is i don't think it's meant to be
funny but it is hilarious um but
actually it's it's a fantastic movie and
i watched it with my kids about three
months ago and they and it's brilliant
it's a genuinely great film so time for
me to confess
um
i went to all the locations where it was
filmed at
yeah it's like one mountain range over
in the alabama hills
i went to the western museum of film
where they have all the props
no right from tremors
huh oh yeah they had the big worm heads
and one word have worm
heads from uh
two i think it was trimmers two
you know but yeah the area california
called the alabama hills where i mean
it's um
where tony stark lets off the jericho
missiles for the first time you just see
him behind him uh that's the same place
it's just
this
i mean it's been star trek i mean
everything's been filming oh yeah
so yeah i went to all the the the i took
the trimmer tour
now see i actually think that's that's
that's quite cool i don't know why
you're embarrassed about that i think
that's cool and the the thing i love
about that it's when it's had loads of
sequels and
one of those underrated films that
nobody watched and then slowly i think
maybe as kevin bacon became famous
people went back maybe to watch it but
it's a great movie and the psycho with
the all the weapons and the in this
bunker i just and his elephant gun i
just love that guy and he's the guy that
only ended up they made a tremors movie
about five years ago and he stars in it
yeah they've made about six now and
they're five or six or something
i sent you a little surprise on facebook
messenger see just on this topic
have i got some photos of you
idiot we had to wait for everyone else
to clear out before i could do this and
not laugh but yeah
all yours
yeah
this is my childhood we're just going
through my childhood because i used to
watch we had a thing over in the uk and
it was like on channel 4
because we have our proper channels so
we have bbc one bbc two obviously in itv
but before we had cable and skye and we
had channel four and they used to have
crafts so on a on a friday night and
this jonathan ross used to present this
tv show and they just basically used to
show these crappy movies
and this is when i fell in love with
them it was like um
a samurai cop and things like this just
just like stupid movies um oh the one
was um i remember distinctly it was
oh it was like american
samurai or something like that it was
called but it was the guy from the bruce
willis movie i'm not bruce willis oh
bruce lee uh enter the dragon do you
remember the guy that um uh he's he's a
womanizer and he he gets out he gets
like five or six different women and
then says you pick one and he goes i'll
take you you and you something
he's great in that movie but he actually
starts in this this samurai i was awful
oh
terrible killed his career but that was
what we had on a friday night and think
so i watched all these terrible movies
back then that was when i saw critters
for the first time i saw tremors
and um
and they just have like you know a lot
of old um john saxon was in it as well
he was great he's not the guy i'm
thinking about he's the black guy that
i'm thinking a guy thinking about it it
wasn't john saxon that was um
um
the character i think about but john
saxon was weird as well he was the big
star in that movie supposedly but people
forget he was even in it but he was
supposed to be they
they they had bruce lee but they thought
that um
[Music]
he wouldn't be a big enough paul
so they got john saxon to appear in the
movie and people forget who's even in
but um the guys was good
what was the other sean connery movie i
wanted to mention
um
it wasn't a b movie but it was
had a lot of money behind it but it was
league of extraordinary gentlemen
i i i'm with you on that one though
because it is kind of i think it is kind
of a b movie
a massive budget
yeah most of them
went on sean connery
well yeah
they paid him a lot of i loved that film
when it came out i i loved i loved the
invisible man character he was kind of
funny mm-hmm um i loved the nemo
character and that's so oh my god right
um even though i don't think they quite
understood the um how venice works
because that massive submarine was
hiding under the water and then appeared
and went through the sea and i'm like
it's only about that deep but i don't
know whatever
um
sean connor was in zardoz as well he was
that's true yeah
um that's a great film but it was um
but i i think it definitely comes into
the genre we're talking about because it
was funny in places and it did not mean
to be
um they were hoping to set up a big
franchise why weren't they but it just
bombed because um
i think they advertised it i think they
set it up wrong as well and they
advertised it wrong
but i like the idea of tom sawyer in it
you know
and um
i'm not really i want really gassed with
the uh the actor that did it
uh but i like the idea of
you know tom sawyer being like this
uh 18th century-ish
superhero you know
yeah i like that
um allen's just mentioned the last star
fighter
yes
that was a great film no what are are
they going to do a series is there a
series are they remaking that they are
rebooting it but i think they keep
changing the minds at one point it was
going to be a movie and now i think it's
going to be a serious
um but it keeps i think i think we
probably were on our tv screens if it
wasn't for
for code
um but yeah apparently is it is in the
works is being developed
so fingers crossed on that one because i
think that'd be a good one i love that
film
excuse me it's quite a good um
plot
mm-hmm really i quite liked it i liked
it you know yeah
um
and i want to see the uh the the one
character come back i got more name the
guy that actually put the
the machine up i can't remember his name
there
but anyway it was a good phone and the
um i like the uh the what was it the
rose what's the weapon called
what's it called
here
they spin around it's called rose
something
rosewood now i forget anyway but no
great film great phone i'd love to see
that
um
so more modern
a couple of modern thoughts one film
that i am a little bit embarrassed i
like
was the abraham lincoln vampire hunter
movie
i'm embarrassed that i liked it though
so much that's blossom that's why i'm
getting ready
yeah yeah yeah
no but uh abraham lincoln vampire hunter
i mean it
uh you grope me growing up in uh
in the south
in america
is like
there was so much other hidden stuff he
if you didn't live in the south you just
didn't get
you know i was just like little tiny
touches like oh [ __ ] they actually did
their research here you know and um
it was just a great movie the whole
thing the underground railroad and it
was just it was just so well done
yeah the the only thing i think let it
down a little bit i don't like it when
films
if you're going to take the mickey out
of yourself you've got to
um get the balance right
right and and you but you've got to
you've got to sort of like when you've
got a ridiculous storyline i think
you've got to embrace the stupidity of
it sometimes and you've got to you know
just realize that okay this is a little
bit silly
and we're going to make fun of it i
think the only problem i had with abram
lincoln vampire hunt is they didn't
embrace the silliness at all they
actually tried to make a really serious
movie
and but they have a serious movie with
abraham lincoln in his stove hat and an
axe killing vampires i'm like
they didn't they didn't get that they
went to some movies go way too far the
other way and they just do they just
they they embrace the silliness too much
and i remember the um
thunderbirds movie they did a few years
ago
and i can't remember his name but the
guy from er was in it he was he was one
of the likeable actors in er
not george clooney one of the other ones
um
and he um
he at one point he played brains and at
one point the bad guy um played by ben
kingsley put a microchip at the back of
his head so that i could control him and
so he walked around like that sort of
like like like the puppets did from
thunderbirds and i was just like oh
god
yeah i wanted my fingers in my eyes so i
didn't have to watch it anymore i was
just like
no
so they just went completely
the wrong way with that and this had
complete silliness you know
um
but but abraham lincoln the vampire
slayer went completely other way and
pretended like this isn't silly
it's abraham lincoln's killing vampires
what's wrong it is
yeah um get your history right bud
exactly he killed vampire that's why we
have no vampires and why he was such a
brilliant president if only trump killed
some vampires if we wouldn't or
werewolves or something oh well or
something worthwhile instead of just
eating you know killing his dinner every
night and a lot of it and he really uh
is like arnold burger king or whatever i
mean he did
yeah
the white house has some of the best the
best chefs in the world and
the the those chefs are
members of the united states navy right
and they're tasked with feeding the
president
he would order out mcdonald's
he's an idiot
anyway no politics no politics
the ukraine oh god world war ii
um it's going to happen
bishop troopers gotta talk about that
little one storm ship really thank you
troopers
um he's nearly i know what he meant um
look at me man what are you talking
about
you had cool ships thunderbird 2 is one
of the coolest ships ever done a big one
maybe needed modernizing and
you have a really brilliant storyline
idea and jonathan frakes just went in
and went let's just [ __ ] it up and he
just he just made a bad movie i just
don't know why he did it and they just
they did it with all the kids running
around the thunderbirds were all trapped
by the the bad guy by ben kingsley and
it was it was the kids that had to save
the day and i'm like bollocks to that i
want to see what the thunderbirds are
doing
the other film where the thunderbirds
attract was a far more interesting movie
but they didn't make that one they made
one with a bloody teenage kids running
around going
um
it's the perfect
perfect example of when film goes badly
wrong
starship troopers
well before we get to the starship
troopers i just want to say the best
thunderbirds movie ever was team america
world police which was not a
thunderbirds movie
but i'm oh my god if that was just you
know
we're going to go back to base and then
cocktails
start trimming our ship troopers
and he says um
he goes uh
you have to promise that you're going to
come back
and he just turns around
i promise
there's a sex scene
with puppets i just said this film's the
international sign for him distressed
[Laughter]
it's just a great movie those guys i'd
love um
i i just love um trey matt park i just
think they're fantastic i love
the when i went to see south park the
movie
it's one of the only comedies i've ever
i've ever seen at the cinema anyway and
i've actually just like properly belly
like almost crying laughed all the way
through
um saddam hussein with a with a
a a male appendage toy guy ah come on
guy
let's say some things
just
that's one of those films that i wish i
didn't like as much as i did
i like that film far more than i should
and just uh just just eric cartman i
actually called um i shouldn't i
shouldn't
admit this on in public but i actually
call my my daughter after eric cartman
we called her erica
that poor kid and i'm like
um therapeutics the the therapy couch
she's just
yeah yeah yeah she's gonna spend some
time here because of yeah she doesn't
know it's fine
she's not watching this
starship troopers starship troopers was
and
it is a pretty bad movie really in front
of them um it's paul verhoeven isn't i
think maybe yeah from memory it's one of
the it was one of the first very early
movies to break 100 million to cost to
produce which is now
nothing nothing and that's like robert
downey jr's fee for the uh the last
um marvel movie so um
so um but you know that was one of those
things and they they said um paul has
they basically said right you've got
this much money to make the film and
he's like all the special effects are
going to cost this much money how am i
going to do this so we want well i'll
just hire nobody's
um literally
uh you know um oh what's his name he was
in he was barney from um
doogie howser
and barney from how i met your mother
uh
oh right right right uh yeah
uh he was he's the only actor i knew in
it but he was that was in his
downward thing before how i met your
mother and barney became popular he had
never he hadn't had a job since doogie
howser so that's the only reason he's in
it
um
the main actor
who's got a very casper
van dien
casp or something that's your cat uh
casper van diem yeah they go um he is
the world's worst actor
um he's just he's just so cardboard it's
like he can't read um it's like he's he
struggles with you know it's like
somebody's having to like tell him his
lines and his ear and he's just sort of
like repeating it he's like
um
rico's
roughnecks um it's just a bad film but
it's a wicked movie i i've watched a
movie probably about 30 times
um
dean d-i-e-n
dean denise
yeah and neil patrick harris neil
patrick harris thank you he's great
though he's brilliant and everything i
love neil patrick harris um i love every
halloween i google his and what he's
dressed up as
with his family he gets his husbands and
his kids and they dress up as a crazy
just if you've got summers go google uh
neil patrick harris's halloween costumes
they're fantastic
and he's poor kids
they're they're dragged into as well and
they're just brilliant
um
but um that reminds me he was in the
um they did a
sleepy hollow movie
and um
he was in that casper vandin was that he
was terrible in that as well
and with um
alleged wife peter and captain
oh
one of the biggest actors in the history
of the planet and i forgot why you
making me blank on his name
yeah and me anyway he was in it um but
the mobster was in it and he had the fur
file down teeth and he was great
oh i found his name there as well oh god
we're terrible
um that that was from that wasn't from
hell that was the um the
the jack the ripper
um but yeah that would that was a
terrible move he's not sleepy hollow
that wasn't a great fight i love sleepy
hollow and christine
oh yeah oh christina reach out about
christina reid she was in it yeah yeah
katarina manchester yeah johnny depp
yeah
he was like
christopher walken played that and he
was brilliant in it he played he was
properly scary in that film
um but but yeah i've forgotten christina
ritchie was in it what happened to
christina ricci
uh she's just
she's still out there acting on
producers let's look her up i remember
last time i saw her in anything uh
there's christina ricci
and um there's a series of yellow
jackets that she's in
oh
she did uh matrix resurrections and
she's uh
she's a voice on rick and morty
uh so she's still working there oh yeah
guardians like winona ryder they always
thought that she'd be huge for them but
i saw christine richie must still be
quite young
she did that speed race so she was great
at that
that's a terrible movie but she was
couldn't it 80
20 she's 42.
my age for her birthday last week
i could i could call christina richie
she's within my age bracket i could do
that
going back to uh
sleepy hollow
the guy that played uh
the uh
oh the magistrate what's his name
phillips phillips yes
he was played by mr dursley the guy that
played mr dursley on harry potter
oh okay of course he was and the guy
from the red wedding as well no no no no
no no no no no it's not it's not the
same guy dursley is the um yeah he's he
played he was in a big detective series
over here he was great um
something pie
and he was great in that um it's dead
now heart attack yeah i think so not not
really a shock to be honest he was a big
fella but yeah
um
other movies we got in here
uh i've got i've got um
i don't know you how familiar are you
with uh roger corman
you have to remind me like um roger
corman back in the day he was like the
king of b-movies
i'd probably always face them we'll
probably not know his name uh let me
rattle off some of the um
films he did i get way back
high in the sky thank you
you do like dozens of movies uh uh
a year
um little shop of horrors he was the
producer for for 1960 house of usher
1960
um tales of terror 1962 the raven 63
uh the man with the x-ray high 63
dimension 13 63
uh queen of blood 1966
um
i mean he was the i mean he's got
hundreds and hundreds of credits roger
corman with a c
um
i mean the uh the
ron howard's first directorial
uh job was working for uh roger corman
i'm trying to find figure out which one
that was um
corman's legendary huh i'm sorry i just
started just put a quick comment up
about flash gordon full soundtrack by
squeeze that's right
is having a reboot that will be
on backing our screens in the next
couple years
see how they do with that
we're going sorry but yeah so it was um
ron howard's first directorial debut and
roger corbin was famous for telling him
look kid
if you do a good job for me you'll never
have to work for me again
and my own it was really good at uh
schlock
and just you know b movies in general
and my favorite one that he did was she
gods of shark reef
have you ever seen that oh right the the
two brothers it's shipwrecked one's like
a sketchy murder guy
and they've landed on this island full
of
young nubile women who are hiding the
secret uh treasure of pearls and
yeah she gods of shark reef
i think i've seen that that was a that
was one of those yeah i'm not the
greatest movies in the world um
somebody just mentioned here about um
brian blessed that's my one problem with
them making um
flash gordon
because brian blessed actually even
though he's like 95 years old and he
still tries to climb everest and he's
still an amazing human being
but without
flash gordon's a lot people i don't know
how that i don't i don't think there's
not much point making that movie trust
it's the only bit in the film i remember
and um but but yeah we'll see if we get
that again um yeah um josh smith was
just about how dust on on youtube
channel does a lot of really amazing
sci-fi getting there yeah not really b
movies because they do some really quite
heavy stuff but um yeah
it's it's some of the best sci-fi about
at the moment
um i mean i i subscribe to that it's
dirt cheap you know a lot of it is a
shorter stuff but it's really intense
really clever really stuff that makes
you think i think
um
the
sci-fi though is really um
it's really in vogue at the moment man
you look at all the stuff that's being
remade at the moment and i wish they'd
have the big argument i wish they'd come
up with some more
new things but i mean we do have we do
have new stuff i mean i've just finished
watching racing dion on netflix and i
honestly think i just love that show i
think it's one of the one of the
cleverest most sort of new
superhero shows out there at the moment
i think it's great um so there is new
stuff out there
there's a lot of new stuff on the sci-fi
channel if you get on the next sci-fi
network you go watch it it's just not
very well
funded
so it's not the greatest tv in the world
but but it's you know it's out there but
um if you look at all the stuff there
like rebooting re
making at the moment it's all sci-fi
from back in the 80s 90s and
and stuff you know it's like um
[Music]
we're in a we're in a we're in a happy
time to be sci-fi fans at the moment i
think we are i mean it's
i you know
in the 70s 80s and 90s you had to go if
you want to see sci-fi you had to go to
the theater you know or weed
uh there was very very little
and you had to just make it work for
yourself you know you just you'd come
out and you just have to get get all of
your uh sci-fi on in very short meals
but man these days
it's totally different
and they've been there fighting over all
the um the all the big executives and
moments you know it's like all the big
streaming services they're fighting over
which thing which is one reason why the
expanse will almost certainly get its
last three seasons made it's because if
amazon don't know someone else will
um you know um
so yeah i think it's i think it's just a
matter of time
but i think so
let's see i think i might have exhausted
my list mate to be honest have you i was
told i had to mention detective pikachu
um as when i mentioned it to our friends
from aliens and stuff that they were
that i was going to do this tonight
their immediate answer was um we've got
to mention
um so i i i mentioned it before we came
on and said both of us immediately went
i love that film i don't know why
they're messing up it was a brilliant
film it was wonderful
i don't want to i shouldn't i don't
really want to admit publicly that i
love that film but
i love ryan reynolds so to be honest so
i just love anything else does so
so anyway the the movie that uh ron
howard did for roger corman it really
kick-started his uh film career was
grand theft auto
1977.
was that then i'm assuming that then
inspired the game so i've not seen that
yeah it's forever ago you know 1977 was
when it came out
but yeah it was that's what really he
famously said if you do a good job on
this film you'll never have to work for
me again
there's another film that
i'm kind of ashamed i love it
it's not an american film it's a jet and
i think it's a japanese film that was
done for someone's film project in film
school i'm not sure it's got a crazy
history but it's called tetsuo the iron
man
okay
tetsuo is like it's this uh guy
he's like a regular just kind of a
japanese business dude company man
and he gets
scratched
or has an accident where he gets metal
in him
and then he ends the next hour whatever
turning into this
electrical monstrosity you know where
he's he has this big auger drill for
penis and he kills this woman and it's
just a lot of it is uh that's how
science works
exactly right
and uh but it it's a it's the the the
the mechanoid or whatever slowly takes
over his human body and a lot of it is
in stop motion and a lot of it is just
this insane
soundtrack
just insane orchestration behind it's
just tetsuo the ironman not tetsuo the
body hammer which is when they try to
pay him real studio money there's
something got lost in translation
between
iron man and body hammer body hammer is
in full color and it just i don't know
the grit
was lost i think it's just iron we
i mean all night actually talking about
like old b movies and things we've not
mentioned any other japanese
projects but i mean like the old
godzilla films and oh gosh yeah yeah and
china and um i think there's some came
out golden harvest i think did a couple
like things like um the guyver
yeah things like that those are all um
that those are early manga oh yeah
there's one there's one that really
comes to mind
[Music]
i have to do this remember you to go
searching i really should bring my
laptop up and start search things yeah i
know yeah it's just what was that there
was one is um
early 90s maybe let's see um
is after killers
it was hard boiled
fat
hard-boiled holy [ __ ]
it was a let's just
call it a shoot him up
what it was
and hard worked it was like this you
know it was just
buddy team they're trying to shoot down
you know or or squash
you know mob crime and that
but it was just so kinetic
who director director was john wu
where's one of john woozle
92 i think it was before face-off there
you go yeah
right yeah uh yes
it was one of the first
films by wu that actually kind of
permeate or got into
american film culture hard boiled loved
it opening scene we're gonna shoot up a
tea shop
i love the the the cinema technique they
use to add kinetic energy to a scene
there's all this paper floating around
you know watch it you just the paper's
not coming from anywhere but there's all
this paper floating around the air just
makes it a really anxious scene it's a
really cool film technique and it's just
chao young fat man he's probably one of
the best actors
to yeah he's definitely
he's that though with michelle you and
that type of
um yes or um
the physicality of what they were
capable of was phenomenal
he did change in fact did um it is him
isn't it that did bulletproof monk
with sean williams scott
i think uh yes yes bulletproof yeah yeah
yeah
crouching tiger hidden dragon did that
too i thought the bulletproof one was a
great movie
i thought that was um shawn if scott was
going to become a bit of an action hero
after that and it just didn't
scott seemed to take jobs where he got
beat up a lot you know yeah
g-force god i love that um it is being
rebooted that that is true i've heard
about myself that is being rebooted
there's um there's a couple of those um
old things that are coming back as cgi
cartoons as well the other one was a
space force
that's coming back uh
what was the one it had the cubes and
the balls and the terra hawks
terre haute is a jerry anderson series
that's that's apparently going to be
quite bad read the cubes in the balls
and that i couldn't remember yet that's
that's all i can remember
but yeah
um terra hawks is coming back and
someone else as well the one with them
they're all dressed as birds and they've
got they've got beaks on their hats
there's a cartoon there's a wicked
spaceship
um battle my god it's like you are
thinking of my brain battle of the
planets
it's like our brains are just worn
that's terrifying and that's apparently
coming back as well that's going to be
remade into a uh computer animated
um serious sort of thing a bit like they
did with them
which one
which one my brain just don't stopped
working
i got a couple more you know uh this is
a an 87 movie the house two
the second story it was
um
it was really i was that was story spelt
s-t-o-r-y
it's america we don't care
yeah you just randomly drop letters
afterwards all the time
aluminium who needs all those damn eyes
get that [ __ ] out of here no but this
was uh there was this um these kids
apparently inherited get a house
and uh
some sort of family house and um
grandpa is you know this old western
cowboy's dead is buried in the backyard
from the 1800s but he's not exactly dead
because he comes back as kind of a mummy
and there's this like mayan crypt
underneath the house of course john
ratzenberger comes in to
uh
beat back the mayan
warriors because he has to get back for
little league it would
not even joking i just realized i've
seen this movie
described it i'm sorry
that sounds like a film i remember
watching it
but i loved it i mean it was just it was
yeah
yeah yeah ratson burgers in that one too
but yeah i it was just so campy that it
tried to be serious but it just really
turned into this uh comedy and it was
just really good
i mean i think
bill maher the comedian guy on from
has a show on uh hbo yeah real time he's
in it i think as a very young
he's always tried to be an actor wasn't
he yeah yeah and he basically become a
comedian because he couldn't get jobs
acting right exactly a huge conspiracy
theorist just
believes in illuminati and all sorts
but anyway
that was so that was the house too i
wanted to get that one in
uh
american werewolf in london
but i was really when i first saw it in
the theater i was really
really hammered
i was literally terrified out i mean i
was sideways in my seat so terrified
but there would there was like vodka
involved a lot of vodka and but i really
didn't like the movie after i saw it
again
sober
yeah
it's one of those
was the actor the guy from um
who then played
in gremlins
was that him
about the same guy somebody somebody in
the comments will tell me
but um no that was one of those films
that was like uh we had a bit of a
renaissance of british
side of sci-fi briefly
was another film about the same time
which it was a space movie um it was
aliens alien vampires were coming down
as a teenage boy i love this film
because the first 10 minutes to film
there's just this alien chick wandering
around completely naked
um
oh
yes awesome
um i can't know what it's called but but
yeah we made movies for a bit and they
didn't they didn't do great so i mean we
we just started making movies for the
americans again but um what was that
damn film called
should be burned into my mind
just google
sci-fi movie where a chick wanders
around naked for the first 10 minutes
and someone will come up it probably
won't be something that your wife would
like you
to see in your search history
um i was on the tip of my tongue that
didn't come to me then
uh was it let's see wandering girl now
barefoot single white female
it's a british movie
i put british to see a british movie
you'll find it um
as soon as you tell me the title i'll
i'll kick myself but that's actually not
a bad sci-fi movie that's quite gory as
well and stuff in places
um it's like when we make quite like
when we make things like event horizon
and films like that we're quite good at
the sci-fi horror
genre um
lights horse
stupid cumberdale beat you by that
hubert
thank you we're i think we're about
three all with the um with the uh for
the comments tonight
they've beat us three times we've beat
them three times so uh
i'm calling that draw
um but um moral victory cause i'm doing
i'm trying to do this from memory but
yeah life force great film i'm really
good i'm not saying yes he was on he was
on channel again channel no it's on
channel five channel five is where
entertainment goes to die in this
country
um
so uh it's i saw it on like i saw it on
channel five
years after
oh so i just realized john smith got it
before on but hubert did
so well they uh
yeah okay they they're beating us now
but um all right i guess i i'm gonna
unless is there anything else on your
list before we say we
went through the mall
excellent
we've got some brilliant moves that you
need there to go and find on netflix
they won't be on any they won't be on
anything good they'll be somewhere
hidden away on netflix probably they've
noticed netflix definitely the last two
years or so has become the place where
the terrible sequels of films get shown
right but the actual original isn't on
um
it's a good film it's not a netflix but
um a lot of these films will be on there
um oh the other the only other film i
did put down that i actually i'm
embarrassed i enjoyed is sharknado
and i i never watched the others
but a genuine genuine fact which i think
we might have mentioned in police
actually
was that the guy from beverly hills nolo
210 did that appeared in sharknado
um i forget his name blonde curly idiot
earned more money than gal gadot did for
the first wonder woman movie
and we say that hollywood isn't sexist
oh my god that's genuinely true
but um
i love the sharknado films sharks would
just jump out puddles
yeah
it was
terrible but um
once again stormy i'm going to thank you
for coming on and spending your
hard-earned time
talking rubbish on my little channel
you're very real
and everybody in the
comments tonight you've been brilliant
there is not much better than a film you
sit down to and halfway through go this
is brilliant
like um
what was the nazis in space on that was
another one
yes
it's just a great film all the way
through you going why do i like this i
need to think about my life choices i
shouldn't enjoy this
as an adult
you're my inner child just going it's
because it's nazis in space
so we will be back in two
weeks you in
two weeks
yeah everybody that's been on this
evening you've been you've been
legendary um if you have any ideas on
rubbish you want us to talk about
because all we really want to talk about
is our back certain over here it's cold
so my hip hurts
my back is killing me right now man i'm
wiggling all around the screen and i
apologize
um
so but if you've got anything you want
us to have a chat about please get in
the comments today and and let us know
and well
we'll kick some stuff around next time
so stormy
so please i have actually remembered to
put a link for your channel in my
description
i saw that actually that you're pushing
2 000 subscribers so please get over
there guys and subscribe you can
actually learn stuff you'll learn
nothing on my channel but you will
actually learn things on stories
well thank you
so please get over there um
thank you for coming
we will see you
in two weeks have a pleasant evening and
if you're in the uk try not to blow away
trying to like this